Speaker 1: All right, let's get into this
week's mailbag.
Email bag, as many of you know, the e-mail
bag ranges from the extremely low brow, ignorant
and hateful to really interesting ideas, suggestions,
questions, all sorts of different things.
Info at David Pakman dot com is the place
to send your emails.
Remember, we get 500 emails a day and we go
over about eight a week.
So I just want everybody to, you know, I get
e-mails and then I get emails about why haven't
you read my email yet?
And sometimes I get the second one within
hours of the first one, it's like, Hey, guys,
I do sleep sometimes, you know?
OK, let's get to the emails.
First one is from a guy who's been writing
in for a while.
His name is Gary B..
And he said, Did you get your booster yet?
Dumb ass.
And in fact, I did.
I mentioned last week that I was going, This
is an anti-vax nut who's been emailing for
a long time.
I think he writes in sometimes about motor
oil in vaccines, if I recall correctly.
I got my booster on Thursday, got it at 4:30,
went to bed around 11:00, had a little bit
of arm pain and then the next morning woke
up at 7:30.
A little bit feverish, although I didn't have
a fever, headache, headache like behind the
eyes and just achy took a Tylenol with breakfast
and that helped a lot.
Worked the regular day, slept a lot Friday
night and then was basically better on Saturday.
So I am now triple vax than I'm feeling boosted
and all of these different things.
But yes, Gary, thank you for asking.
I did indeed get my booster.
Some call it a third dose.
They're probably coming for everybody, is
what it seems to be given again.
We've got another rise in cases and especially
what we know about the decreased efficacy,
particularly of the JNJ vaccine.
But in general, I, by the way, I got two Moderna
shots as my initial regimen and then I got
a Maddern, a booster as well.
OK, second email from Jake Jake says John
Bolton predicted Trump won't run for president
again in 2024 because he fears being known
as a loser if it doesn't work out.
This is what Michael Cohen keeps saying.
Trump will not run because he can't handle
the potential humiliation these guys close
to Trump seem to be sure of this, Jonathan.
Yeah, I've spoken to Michael Cohen about this
directly, and I think that he's completely
he's making a completely plausible case.
I think the question is we don't yet know
whether Trump is likely to lose in 2024.
As I've said before, if Republicans do well
in twenty two and Biden doesn't do well in
his third year of his presidency, second and
third and into the election cycle and in particular,
if Biden doesn't even run for reelection,
I think that it looks OK for Trump.
I think a Trump vs. Biden rematch is good
for Trump.
I think if Biden doesn't run and Kamala Harris
is the Democratic nominee, I think that's
good for Trump.
So I agree with what Michael Cohen says and
said to me when I was on his show.
I agree I haven't seen this John Bolton thing,
but I'm sure it might be right.
I think if Trump knows he will lose, he won't
do it because he doesn't want to suffer a
humiliation.
I just don't know that it's clear Trump will
lose yet.
And so we're going to be watching that.
It's a question we all care about.
Here's a longer voicemail, but it's a very,
very interesting one.
This one is from Marc, and Mark wanted to
weigh in on why people on the right call me
gay.
Mark, says, David, you asked why people on
the right assume you're gay.
I am a gay man who is politically active,
and I have some ideas based on personal experience
with right wingers.
First, most of us who are actually gay realize
you're straight and you're an ally.
I'm very glad for all the straight allies
we have.
I've never picked up on a gay vibe from you.
My gaydar does not even register as much as
a blip when I watch your YouTube videos listen
to mark.
However, for a lot of people on the right,
particularly the far right, there is just
nothing worse than being gay.
Hence, gay becomes the perfect epithet.
If they don't like your politics, then that
means you're gay.
If they don't like your position on social
issues, then that means you're gay.
If they don't like you, period, that must
be because you're gay and they're straight.
No self-respecting right winger would tolerate
a gay person in their midst, except possibly
those who suddenly decided they were quote
cured.
And we all know how long gay cures last.
Very interesting email from Mark.
So there it is.
It's sort of like a presented without comment.
Very interesting to hear from Mark on that.
Next, the email is from Jessica.
Jessica says, Hi Mr. Pacman, I've walked.
Watched your show for a while now and I've
heard you say you're a progressive, but not
a Democrat.
Would you say you're independent?
Then just wondering since if someone said
they were progressive, I'd think they meant
a progressive democratic.
Love your videos.
Thanks.
So, Jessica, with total peace and love, you
may have a few terms confused.
Progressive is a political ideology.
Sort of like socialist.
Someone says they're a socialist.
They might be a member of the Democratic Party
or not.
They might be a member of the Socialist Party
to the extent that sometimes it exists and
sometimes does not.
But socialists can be an ideology.
Maybe that's a bad example since there is
a socialist party.
Listen, progressive can be a member of the
Democratic Party or not.
I have never been a member of the Democratic
Party.
I am an independent, but I tend to vote for
Democrats when that makes sense in Partizan
elections.
All right, I hope I've cleared it up.
Geez, John says, Hey David, love your channel.
What do you think of the.
What do you think the Democrats are going
to do in 2024?
Joe Biden will be just shy of 82 at the time
of the election.
I suspect that will be a major issue for many
voters.
Do you think he will be renominated or step
aside and support Kamala Harris?
I like Kamala, but I think she's about as
charismatic as Al Gore.
Have the Democrats painted themselves into
a loss in 2024?
John from Indiana Listen, John, it's so early
that we don't have definitive answers to these
questions.
That being said, I have already stated I have
serious concerns.
I think 80 plus year old Joe Biden after being
hammered on by Republicans, rightly or wrongly,
for four years against Trump.
I don't think it looks good for Joe Biden.
If Joe Biden steps aside and the nomination
is given to Kamala Harris or if she wins it
in a contest and then it's Trump versus Kamala.
I don't think it's very good DeSantis versus
Kamala.
I don't think it's very good for Democrats.
So I am very worried about that exact scenario
and painted themselves into a loss is starting
to editorialize in a way that I don't I don't
know that I'm ready to do yet.
But let's just say my policy tends to be I
talk about the next election, which right
now is 2022.
My concerns are so high for 2024 that I have
found myself wandering into talking about
it more than I typically would.
And John from Indiana brings up exactly some
of the concerns that I have.
Next, the Oh, we've got some bonus ones.
These are from Facebook.
These are these are tough.
OK, these are tough.
Someone wrote to me.
And said you need to do more research, doctors
and scientists are speaking out against this
vaccine.
That was all one sentence going on to say
You're just following the lies like a good
little sheep a ton.
You know, there's this idea.
There's this general understanding that Facebook
is particularly a cesspool of anti-vax, non-thinking,
sometimes undereducated rants and raves that
are barely intelligible.
Anecdotally, we're experiencing that we're
experiencing that, and I would say close to
half of the messages we get on our Facebook
page result in the person just being banned
because they're either hurling insults or
otherwise harassing people.
OK?
Another a Facebook special for you today.
Whitten, I'm going to read this as written.
Where do you get your information from, but
we still have our constitutional right of
freedom of choice?
I don't know what in particular this refers
to.
My instinct is that it's somehow vaccination
related as well.
Next one, you were a total and complete piece
of ass pushing lies and conflicting truth
research.
Nuremberg journalists held accountable and
then f yourself with a heated curling iron.
You f-ing worthless sack of s.
You will notice period exclamation point,
which is an interesting grammatical curiosity,
as well as random capitalization of words
like complete journalists.
The F-word yourself SAC is capitalized reminiscent
of Donald Trump.
It's actually very interesting how a lot of
Trumpian lunatics have picked up on this random
capitalization of nouns and other words in
the middle of sentences.
So there's that.
And then lastly, coming perfectly timed on
the heels of what some call a booster and
some call a third dose.
You are so lost, you must have a five.
You must have five g vax second because you
can't be that stupid.
And here we have one two three four different
places where there's just extra spaces between
words.
Random capitalization.
Sentence fragments run on sentence, missing
apostrophe and can't it, it would actually
be so if I said to you, I have a sentence
this long and it has close to double digits
of spelling and grammatical errors, you would
say, Sir, that can't be, but it is, but it
is.
It is hard to believe we are going to be off
next week, Thursday and Friday.
We will have a truncated schedule because
of the Thanksgiving holiday here in the United
States.
Of course, many in our audience don't celebrate
Thanksgiving.
They're not in the United States.
We will have a Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday
show and we will be off Thursday, Friday.
Just don't want people to be worried or think
the show got pulled off the air.
That's next week.
We still have a fantastic bonus show for you
today.
You can sign up at join Packman dot com and
get access to the bonus show.
It's an extra program every day just for you
who say, I am going to support this program
financially.
You can use the coupon code better 21 to get
a discount.
I look forward to seeing you there, or we
will be back Monday
Unidentified: with brand new programing before
you.